what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I honestly did not expect the
x-men MCU video to be as popular as it
was but people loved it so for me I
think that if we're gonna do face to
face to has to pop right like you know
when it comes to a Phase two stage to
you whatever the case may be it has to
not only sort of bring the x-men into
the MCU but it has to continue the trend
of world building while also telling us
as the viewer they're not isolated
they're not existing out there in
no-man's land everything else is still
going on I think that's one of the major
faults that the MCU has had so far like
Captain America the Winter Soldier for
example there's no reason Iron Man or
Thor or The Incredible Hulk should not
have been in that video because there
was so much that happened when you
basically had shield who was essentially
taken over by Hydra launching a campaign
against almost the entire world it just
came down to Captain America and Bucky
Barnes stopping them it would have made
a lot more sense if like Thor had been
in there or Iron Man had been in there
even if it was only a cameo even if it
was only them offering assistance in
Captain America turning him down it
would have created a little more
cohesiveness as opposed to making it
feel like a film that was out there in
no-man's land my goal with Phase two is
to sort of removed that is to take that
problem and throw it out the window the
first thing you do here is the most
logical scenario the x-men meet the
Avengers and is basically the two teams
coming together now in truth because of
the fact that they're only going to be
fighting a singular villain in this film
it makes things pretty easy for us is
basically the two groups coming together
Xavier reveals the fact that he hid the
x-men from the world vision knew about
it vision of course is probably dead
following the events of inity war and so
you know I just kind of have to take it
for what it's worth maybe visions
information was downloaded into Tony
Stark's computers and of course you know
Tony Stark confirms the claims of
Charles Xavier then the groups aren't
necessarily the best of friends they
have somewhat of a tenuous relationship
but you know any sort of you know
problems they may have between each
other aren't severe they don't hate each
other we know you don't immediately jump
into Avengers vs. x-men that doesn't
really happen instead what you do is you
create a sort of trust that exists
between the two of them what you do is
you have a villain come in which
requires both teams to fight against it
the villain you choose is not Magneto
bring back juggernaut juggernaut was
basically thrown in into the origin of
Professor X in the first phase but we
got a glimpse of him we didn't really
know what he was capable of but the
whole idea here is that juggernaut could
single-handedly take on the full
of the Avengers and the x-men at the
same time and inevitably the fight would
just break down to juggernaut versus the
Hulk but the winning scene comes from
the x-men whether it's because they
remove the helmet of Cain Marko and
Xavier uses its telepathy whatever the
case says the x-men are the ones who
save the day and the reason why that
matters is because what it does is it
creates trust between the two groups
now the x-men and the Avengers trust
each other which means going forward
into Phase two we can start seeing more
appearances of the Avengers following
this we need another film that's
basically going to bring in other
characters that Fox owns the rights to
we're gonna bring in Deadpool and what
we're gonna do in this movie is we're
gonna have Deadpool meeting Wolverine
for the very first time but in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
Deadpool now his appearance is gonna be
comedic he might even reference his film
appearances in Fox he'll be zany he'll
be goofy but the gist of this film is a
Deadpool is going to learn that he got
his healing factor from Wolverine in
Marvel Comics because of the fact that
Wolverine was the first major test
subject for the Weapon X project which
is to say successfully drafting
adamantium to the bone structure of
another being when Wolverine escaped
what ended up happening is Weapon X is
basically on the hunt for new candidates
originally when we talked about the
whole idea of Captain America and so on
and so forth and phase 1 and Marvel
Comics originally Captain America was
weapon one the goal of the weapons Plus
project was to create more Captain
America's and they did it in a multitude
of different ways and the problem is
that with it being virtually impossible
to duplicate Captain America when they
found Wolverine and he had a healing
factor and they put adamantium onto his
bones the entire intention of weapons
Plus shifted from making new Captain
America's to making new Wolverines and
so when Wade Wilson was suffering from
cancer in Marvel Comics and he showed up
at this Weapon X facility not knowing
what it was the goal was to give him
Wolverines healing factor you know it
just took a little while for it to kick
in but when it did his healing factor
was more enhanced than Wolverines now
the comedic and the nonsensical element
of these two characters meeting much
like oil and vinegar would be hilarious
because with deadpool learning that he
got his healing factor from wolverine he
would you start calling him dad or
something along those lines I think it'd
be pretty funny I think you'd be pretty
hysterical but it'd be more of just kind
of like a buddy cop film more so than
anything else following this we get back
into serious mode what we do is we
follow the aftermath of Charles Xavier
actions of wiping mutants from the minds
of everybody
existence and this is where we start to
run into one of our first major problems
if Xavier wipes the minds of mute or
wiped the existence of mutants from
everybody on earth how do we justify the
fact that programs like project wide
awake existed back in the 1960s and then
we're never seen or heard from again
well for me it seems kind of simple it's
pretty thin and we might have to find
another way to make this work but for me
all you really do is you just kind of
pick up with that an x-men project wide
awake our third film from phase two in
the x-men Cinematic Universe what you
basically do is you have consequences
for Xavier actions essentially what had
happened in this timeline is that Xavier
had white mutants from the minds of
everybody on earth you know because of
the fact that mutants previously existed
and the government was sort of toying
around with the idea of concerning
themselves with mutants what ended up
happening is when all knowledge was lost
and suddenly those programs were
forgotten about there was no need to
have them anymore
again that is pretty thin I totally
admit that but I can't really find a way
to work around it with mutants basically
stepping into the limelight with the
world learning that mutants exist for
your average person walking around it's
brand-new it's like wow there's mutants
out there and different people would
react different ways but the
undercurrent is you start building this
idea that there are people out there who
hate mutants who do not like them who
believe that mutants are going to
eradicate humanity or they're afraid of
their own existence or sort of suffering
this existential crisis but in terms of
the x-men Project wide awake movie this
deals with the federal government
launching that actual project and the
x-men fighting the Sentinels you
basically have the federal government
take up or really kind of relaunch the
Sentinel program as it existed under
ball of our Trask in the x-men Days of
Future Passed film and then in turn they
hand it to Steven Lane and so what is up
happening is the x-men or at least some
of their group are basically kidnapped
by the Sentinels and taken somewhere now
because some of the x-men have been
kidnapped
the remaining x-men go to the Avengers
for help they basically say we need your
assistance on this now for the most part
that doesn't really work with regards to
the traditional x-men mythos which is to
say and Marvel Comics the x-men they
play things close to the vest they're
very hush-hush when it comes to how
things get done they keep it all
in-house they really don't air their
dirty laundry but what it's designed to
do is show that things are that
desperate desperate times require
desperate measures and that's what you
do here the x-men team up with the
Avengers they take off into space
they fight Stephen Lang they fight his
sentinels the x-men of the Avengers
basically win the day
a captured x-men are rescued and they
start heading back to earth the problem
with this is that on their way back at
the end of this film they're suddenly
hit by cosmic rays and so what this does
is it basically allows Jean Grey
the only x-man there with telepathy the
one person he knows how to pilot a
shuttle because she absorbed all the
information she needed in order to pull
it off she basically grabs the shuttle
shuts down the minds of Tony Stark
Captain America the x-men so on and so
forth and she pilots the shuttle back to
earth crashing into Earth everybody
thinks everything's gonna die Jean Grey
emerges I am Phoenix the x-men and the
Avengers who have regained consciousness
are in a movie ends post credits scene
the post credits scene for this film is
basically the Shiar empire but you don't
know it and you're not told that's what
the Shiar empire is they're monitoring
what's going on on earth and one of them
says we have to alert the magistrate's
it's time things are beginning to go
beyond the Earthlings control and that's
it move on to the next film Jean Grey -
or whatever you want to call it this is
when you start getting into the Phoenix
and what you end up doing here is you
basically give us as the viewer the
origin of the Phoenix it doesn't need to
be huge it doesn't need to be complex it
can be a 20 minute exposition and the
way that you bring this in is following
the Oh Jean Grey and everybody landing
on earth you know you have a couple of
The Avengers who offer the x-men their
aid in terms of analyzing Jean Grey and
seeing what's going on but you bring
back the Charter of the x-men you
basically say them reaching out to the
Avengers for help was like a one-time
thing
now the reason why this matters is
because what it begins to do is so these
very small seeds of distrust this idea
that the Avengers sort of turned as the
turn askew I and say I mean alright I
guess but you know it'd be kind of good
if you were all on the same page and we
all know what we were dealing with
because that sets the stage if we choose
to to basically lead into Avengers vs.
x-men later on down the line but with
this origin of the Phoenix all you do is
spend maybe 20 minutes you know when the
x-men are analyzing Jean they're trying
to figure out what's going on but you
basically learned the Phoenix force
represents the sum total of all life
that has ever currently does or will
ever exist throughout the multiverse you
take the multiverse approach like Doctor
Strange did you tell people it's there
but you don't go super in-depth into it
and that's why that works is because it
kind of hints back at the Doctor Strange
movie and the existence of the
multiverse something that'll probably
hit on again during the events of
infinity war but from there with this
you know 20-minute exposition and the
x-men trying to figure out what's going
on you break away from them for a second
and you focus
group called a Hellfire Club now in
Marvel Comics the Hellfire Club was
basically this large umbrella
organization but the Hellfire Club
contained what was called the inner
circle and the inner circle was a
composed of like Emma Frost and
Sebastian Shaw and mastermind jason
wyngarde it was some of the most
influential or powerful beings who exist
out there now what you do is you have
the Hellfire Club basically realized
Jean Grey's the Phoenix but the overall
gist of the Hellfire Club of the inner
circle is they say our goal is to
basically influence and take over the
world using subversive means and so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
Jean Grey and bring her into the
Hellfire Club in order to make that
happen you use the powers of one of the
Hellfire clubs members a guy named jason
wyngarde
in Marvel Comics jason wyngarde as part
of the Hellfire Club was the guy who was
tasked with bringing Jean Grey into the
group and basically what mastermind is
able to do is manipulate the five senses
and so what he can do is he can trick
you into believing that everything that
you see touch smell taste hear that it's
real that is all actually real and
that's why it's so important is because
in Marvel Comics when jason wyngarde
took over Phoenix she believed
everything that she was seeing was true
and she was operating and basically
being subtly influenced by mastermind
for the purpose of being controlled by
the Hellfire Club and that's what you do
here but with Jean Grey being taken the
x-men scramble they begin to panic the
x-men race off they fight the Hellfire
Club in the midst of the conflict jason
wyngarde uses his powers to make gene
believe Cyclops has died the result is
that with the romance already having
bloom between the two of them Jean Grey
snaps and as a result when she loses her
mind she loses total emotional control
the Phoenix completely takes over and
Jean Grey becomes the Dark Phoenix roll
credits from there you walk away from
everything that's been going on with
Jean the Phoenix force the x-men the
whole nine yards
what you do is you do gambit - and all
gambit - does is it focuses on what Remy
LeBeau has been doing since he's been
kicked out of the x-men
but the biggest brunt of this movie the
biggest focus of this movie is on two
things the first is that you're just
constantly being met with the idea that
different people out there hate mutant
cons you start invoking things like the
Friends of humanity you start bringing
in a lot of these old-school concepts
from Marvel Comics and you begin
building this world that in the
aftermath of everybody learning that the
x-men exists some people laud
some people hate them whatever the case
may be that's background stuff the
biggest emphasis behind it is just
following him as he meets rogue because
when it comes to Marvel Comics gambit
and rogue they go together like like
peas and carrots to quote neo to quote
Forrest Gump but it's cool because rope
is a character we haven't seen yet but
she's also one of the most iconic
members of 1990s x-men and so what you
do is you basically have rogue encounter
gambit in any particular circumstance
but you learn rogues powers she cannot
physically touch another human being
without basically taking their memories
their life energy and their powers if
they have them gambit considers it
somewhat of a challenge but it's sort of
a game between the two of them
ultimately though gambit realizes what's
going on with Jean Grey realizes what's
going on with the Phoenix and that kind
of stuff but he doesn't really care he's
just sort of out there in no-man's land
and is it really worried about what's
going on instead a romance is building
between gambit and rogue from there you
transition back to everything that's
going on with the x-men and you
basically pick up with the dark phoenix
film and what we end up getting here is
this exposition on the origin of the
Shiar empire the group that we saw in
the post-credits scene and you basically
learn the Shiar empire is one of many
alien races that exist out there is
basically an empire unto itself composed
of a multitude of alien races that all
swear loyalty to the Magister or
magistrates you know in this instance
it's lilandra's leading her soldiers to
earth and basically telling the x-men
here is who we are we worship the
Phoenix force or whatever it is we were
its protector Jean Grey in possession of
the Phoenix force is a universal threat
because she's not in control anymore and
so because of that Jean Grey has to die
and so what this does is it leads to a
battle between the x-men and the Shiar
Empire going to war against one another
the other half of this is that you could
basically set up for Avengers vs. x-men
if you wanted to instead of invoking the
Shiar and eliminating that entire
post-credits scene that we had before
what you could basically do is you could
have the Dark Phoenix and you could have
the x-men you could have the Avengers
team up to take down the Dark Phoenix
but in the aftermath of it all The
Avengers start asking the question
should we really trust the x-men can we
really trust this group because in this
scenario we offer aid they kept the
doors close to us and in the aftermath
of this Jean Grey's lost her mind she's
become this Universal entity it took all
kinds of power to basically bring her
down maybe we can't trust the x-men
maybe we should keep a closer eye on
them and so because of that there begins
to so these in
priest you know seeds of distrust and
you basically have this seeds being set
for the x-men and The Avengers going to
war against one another there's any
number of ways that you could do it but
the ending of this movie basically has
to conclude with Jean Grey dying Jean
Grey's physical form has to die the
Phoenix takes off into space or whatever
and that's the end of that the reason
for that is because the final film in
phase 2 is basically an epilogue it's an
aftermath to the death of Jean Grey
it'll be the most somber film that we
have it'll be a funeral for Jean Grey
you know all these different x-men
showing up maybe even some mutants that
we haven't seen before they show up and
then from there it breaks off and do how
each person is dealing with it how is
Charles Xavier dealing with the death of
Jean Grey as the man who mentored her
how do you deal with Wolverine how does
Wolverine handle this when he was in
love with Jean Grey Cyclops was in love
with Jim Gray they were in a
relationship and they were gonna get
married how does he deal with this and
so the movie basically ends with
Wolverine saying I need time alone and
he leaves the x-men that allows you to
go into his own solo film his second
solo film from there Cyclops leaves the
x-men it says I can't handle this this
sacrifice is too much to bear Charles
Xavier himself Ponder's disbanding the
x-men although he doesn't the leaving of
Wolverine the leaving of Cyclops what it
does is it allows the other members of
the classic x-men team the people who
have been the Friends of Jean Grey the
longest Iceman beast
angel they basically walk away from the
x-men they say we can't do this anymore
it's too much of a sacrifice this
emotional toll is too much whatever the
case may be but they basically leave and
so all you're left with is this second
generation of new x-men that are led by
storm
instead of Cyclops maybe in the
aftermath of Jean Grey dying
gambit comes back because rogue
convinced him to gambit rejoins the
x-men and rogue joins as well but
whatever the case is you basically uh
sure in this new generation of x-men
while setting the stage for the
formation of x-factor in phase 3 but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain to make
sure you guys have this sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like this is fun I love doing stuff like
this I think we'll do one with the
Fantastic Four once we're done with the
x-men I love this idea of going through
and just kind of bring characters in to
the to the MCU but I love doing stuff
like this but anyway guys uh we're gonna
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]